good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this Friday's edition of the Friday app
clinic today we're looking at finance
apps my name is reto I'm in and
hopefully we're going to be able to
provide some advice as to how you can
take your finance app and make it all
the better and in honor of finance app
week instead of beer today we're
drinking hedrick's dry martinis and
that's keeping it classy two olives and
a spanish paper Wow taking it to time I
hope so I tried to find the richest
person I knew and the our closest I
could come was Ian does out of a BMW
that's true my wife bought it I said a
look would make me rich in two ways oh I
hope she's watching it on to get full
credit hey course she's not watching at
home she'd be watching at work mm I
would make no sense exactly so right we
we took a look at several financial apps
that work of course suggested by viewers
now we weren't able to look at all of
them and part of the reason is that
financial apps by their very nature
can't ask for some sensitive information
and neither one of us were comfortable
giving our bank accounts to a
third-party sister which actually when
you think about it is is a little silly
maybe possibly and certainly some of the
apps i think mint in particular was one
app which has gotten huge reviews it's
an editor's choice it's by all accounts
very trustworthy and a very high quality
act so in a way i felt like people have
already looked at this and said how
great it is so we can get in point of
fact we have already looked at it George
closely with that team we love it I've
seen it in beta but yeah I didn't it's
not so much I didn't want to trust mint
with my credentials I just didn't want
to show everybody my financial is on air
that's a fickle uh yeah the sheer amount
of beer budget I think would have really
boggled people's minds mmm
you don't want to shock anyone to to
dramatically so yes that makes sense
sadly neither of us has a cayman islands
account that we can use to just you know
demonstrate how it would work so you'll
have to try that yourselves at home but
what we do have is a brand-new
microphones and a couple new cameras
today so before we get into it we just
want to show stuff off we're on the new
microphones which are high quality
microphones as opposed to the ones that
we got on like any an amazon or
overstock sale for like 400 bucks for
four of them mm-hmm I would just fender
there eight now this is about good news
for the local karaoke team who will
really enjoy being able to use those
mics exactly so if you have any comments
about the sound quality just keeping
yourself to it we don't know just
kidding uh so Daniel Pham our engineer
is looking out for sound quality um but
if he misses anything just let us know
speaking of Daniel Pham let's switch
over the engineer cam which I don't have
one of you know later guys later guys
all right no engineer can't quite yet
know what sort move yeah we got it you
can see engineer can ya blue hey guys
whoa that's right we move the lights
after we set up yes right right in my
face I'm gonna move over nice I have the
Sun in the studio now so we're hoping to
get some some betel y quality as well
indeed although i think we are still
getting this
okay okay all right it's all right all
right all right okay so let's suppose we
want to get slightly less meta and have
a look at some apps so we've got a few
what we're going to try get through as
many of these as we can and they
represent quite a very large variation
in app type so I think it's fair to say
yeah i think you know we talked about
financial apps and i think that our
viewers took that a lot of different
ways absolutely um everything from app
sale to i owe you to that mole free
exactly which i noticed that you haven't
installed maybe you didn't realize that
it's all about managing your finances
this is sort of a metaphor that's
interesting well i did see the game and
I thought this is a game well you might
have it is a game in the same way that
light life is a game yeah in fact it's a
disappointed that no one's nominated the
game of life because I guess would have
been an interesting opportunity indeed
oh so why don't we taking a short look
at absence absolutely uh this is a I
guess its financial and way but not
quite the way we it's about saving money
I suppose rather than managing your
finances how she's totally legitimate so
this is kind of an interesting we think
that it might skirt the line on on
google play store policies so but what
it does is it tracks the the prices the
maps on the google play store so that
you can be notified if something goes
like a very nice which it has a nice
people i fairly straightforward using an
action bar it's not actually in action
bar it's more of a pseudo action dog but
you know that's okay you know we're
seeing a lot of this right now we're
seeing a lot of fake action bars why do
you think that it's probably because
there's no framework way of being able
to have action bars for devices running
new of all the versions of battery oh
yeah thank you me too diversity black
bob shell does provide something very
authentic and gives you that ability
that said I think what's what's
happening in the top here is is totally
legitimate you know it is a nap it's an
action bar works the way that you would
expect it to
the only feedback I'd give in this
particular instance is to be careful
about the icons the style of the icons
that you're using and so in this case
they're they're using sort of the themed
the icons so that they you know sort of
faded into the action bar itself it's an
interesting approach but that's
immediately what makes it obvious that
this isn't you know a standard action
bar so I would have a look at the design
side and stick to the design guidelines
in terms of your icons right so I think
what we've over and over is that if you
have a great design idea that doesn't
fit into our design guidelines by all
means use it but if you're trying to
mimic something that the Android design
guidelines already cover and it looks
enough like a standard Android feature
that people might think it is then don't
make it work differently and you
preferably don't make it look
particularly exactly i think that's the
key here it's like if you want to do
something radically different and that's
a fantastic idea you know we love to see
really innovative designs but if you're
doing something which is supposed to
which looks like an action bar or any
other sort of system element it should
it should behave the same way and should
look as close to it as possible so that
you're not sort of getting thrown right
now speaking of icons I think that's
actually my biggest concern about this
appellation i should say right off the
top I love this out I'm sorry the value
that this app exists I love the idea
behind it but there's one thing that I
am concerned about and that is that the
app is using these icons which represent
each of the applications now those
applications have uploaded a icons to
the google play store and given google
permission to use that art word and
their artwork does actually belong to
the people who have created the
applications this creature I so to the
people made out sales on you know the
one thing that I would want to be sure
of it of course I have no idea um but in
general you want to make sure that you
have
negotiated the rights to these icons
before you use them because you don't
necessarily have permission to use them
in this context that's right and in this
instance I imagine it's not going to be
too hard to get that approval if you're
able to reach out because you're
basically helping people to sell their
apps when they've got them on sale so
it's it's free advertising but as Ian
says just because it is definitely
useful for them doesn't mean that you
automatically get the right to use them
yeah the other thing which I'm going to
look at I'm not actually going to click
it because then i will have seen
something which can't be unseen but it
implies here that perhaps this is going
to link me to something which is not
downloadable from the Google Play Store
which would be a violation of the
content policies which says that you
can't link to an external app store if
you want to do I have app downloads it's
got to beat your google play so I'm not
going to click it and that way I won't
know but if the developer of app sales
is out there I would definitely look
carefully at about make sure you're not
violating any of our policies exactly
okay so I think that's all we need is a
really cool idea hmm definitely
definitely you know need to maybe take
care because any time you get into app
information at all there's a bunch of
Twitter Lea little legal and policy
issues but really you really need to
take care of absolutely it's it's a
great idea and as an engineer I think we
can all get on board it's the sort of
thing where you think hey this would be
really cool you know an app which tracks
what apps are for sale I would be really
useful & it is but then you know sadly
the the legal policy stuff it's in the
way and you kind of have to you know do
you do your due diligence find out what
you can encounter yeah you know what
else would be awesome so it's just a
site where I could go and just find free
movies and then I would just download
that I'm really feminine be useful yes
exactly but possibly also some legal
implications not everything we want to
have happen is is legal in today's world
contact your representatives
so should we go to timesheet let's let's
check out timesheets yeah absolutely
i'll fire up here on the air as you can
probably see we have a one of our new
cameras is giving us a different view of
the phone camp so hopefully this is
easier for a front to see at home and
with 90 to 100 percent fewer reflections
yes so this is a this is kind of an
interesting app you know those of you
who who like me has has done contract
work in the past or you know run your
own business then the idea of having to
keep timesheets is as familiar as it is
frustrating you know I I probably
shouldn't admit this but I actually had
a dream two nights ago where you were
chasing me around trying to make me fill
out a time and then you explained that
all time spent on personal calls could
not be included in my google work day
yeah that doesn't sound like something I
would do I need to see somebody you do
need to sit down I think maybe next week
we can have self-help apps that might
help you out all right so--okay so
looking at the looking at the app
straight away what I found kind of
interesting about this was it wasn't the
navigation I guess was the problem to
put it in a nutshell the look and field
is great you've got the the action bar
along the top using you know standard
icons you know exactly what's going on
so the first time I care and I kind of
like this this to deal with this so more
like it exactly and it's it's in a nice
sort of cursive font sort of giving you
a hint as to what's going on so once
you've got things set up that's fair
enough so we are in the app clinic so I
should start working still working on a
task so you can stop working have a
break all these sorts of things it does
actually stick it into your ongoing
notifications so you can continue doing
other work that's very cool and and you
notified when that's happening at second
break
okay now let's continue perfect as who
are now interestingly we have to now put
in detail browse away the break I did
actually it was quite refreshing and
safe so is this interesting so again
here we have an interesting workflow
dynamic where were asked to save the
description for the break that we're
editing right now given the way that
this worked as in i finished my break
and then straight away we were dumped
into this edit break there is really no
circumstance here where I wouldn't want
to save what I've done right so you can
probably get rid of your save icon and
just and the trash icon and just
basically allow you to hit back or we'll
hit up yeah and there's really two
problems here because even if you did
determine through let's say extensive
user experience testing that having a
save button and cancel button it was the
right thing to do there are common icons
for that there's a little check box come
meaning done yes which implies saving
and there's an X meeting canceled so the
little disk icon although I do realize
that the floppy disk is a universal save
symbol we don't use it on Android we
have our own set of icons you should
always use the system icons wherever
possible because that will help not only
help your app be understandable to users
but help the entire ecosystem the
learnable in date and one of the
benefits you get from using those system
icons as well is that everything will be
sized and shaped the same way and in the
same style so you're looking at this
what I know to be a trash icon because
I'm expecting it to be a trash icon but
could just as easily be a birthday
present or a spaghetti pot or a
spaghetti pot yeah that's better
actually the slightly oversized lid yeah
so you know you don't want users to have
to try and interpret what your glyphs
are you just want it to be
straightforward you want to get rid of
them wherever you can so that's what's
uh what's on your plumber I was
wondering about that myself okay you
know what I like having settings on the
overflow menu and I personally I don't
think that everybody agrees with me on
this
not a requirement I personally like
having settings be pretty much
accessible everywhere I kind of agree i
think if you've got sort of these
universal application things like
settings back up and the support page if
you have them anywhere you may as well
have them everywhere I think that makes
it easy you don't want to have to
navigate your app to figure out where
you can get to settings gotta feeling
that's reasonable but now let's see what
happens okay so cancelled okay so once
again we had three way no four ways of
leaving that particular activity one was
the up affordance the other one was the
back key are we coming that the back
affordance down I think just the back
not really sure what affordance even
means but it seems really really smart
it does it really does so the up
affordance vertical y-axis positive
affordance it took us back the back key
i would assume probably it also do seem
innocent and then you've also got the
you know done and cancel or save and
cancel um so for ways to exit that
activity yeah not all of which were self
explanatory not and old but one will
actually cancel what you were doing
which seemed weird right yeah to be
honest I'm a little stuck now because I
took a break I ended the break and then
I had to describe the break but then I
can't feel like describing the brakes so
just laughed but now did I not take a
break or do I just not have the break
described I'm not sure I think it
depends on whether this app has a power
to manipulate time do you feel like
you've had a break no I should probably
have another break yeah
all right breaks over back to work ok so
now I'm going to hit save this time ok
so that we go back brakes successfully
save so again this is something which we
we talked about last week and something
that we've discussed internally as a
team is this notion of using toasts to
inform people when things happen and my
feeling is this is kind of a developer
hack it's the way that you say hey I'm
not entirely convinced that my code does
what I expect it to so every time I'm
going to do something I'm going to pop
up a notification telling me so that
when i hit save i know that my service
has in fact kicked often and saved in
the background yeah i mean when you put
a toast in you're basically saying i
have something to say but it is
completely unimportant exactly because
if you miss it I don't care so what you
really want to be doing here is having
the faith in your own app so by all
means have toasts in the same way that
you have log statements so that when
you're doing your own testing when
you're figuring out whether your
workflows all work and you're pressing
the backs and the absent and confirming
what does one that makes total sense but
before you ship you should probably be
able to move pretty much all your toasts
most of them I mean they're there
certainly are times when I appreciate a
toaster to vesting in the morning mm-hmm
after a late night indeed with a
soft-boiled egg exactly no approach
usually but yeah no that's nice yeah but
in this case I don't know one of the
main issues that I have is that this
particular toast was telling me that
something that I've been working on was
rejected because I happen to hit the
wrong month yeah and in that case I to
me that's not toast worthy that's that's
more of a flashing you know Drudge
Report like saying you know something
has gone seriously wrong hmm but that's
just me I mean I don't the main question
is did I still take that break how would
we find out well i don't know let's have
a look so I'm looking at this I'm going
to go ahead and assume that the way we
have done the bottom here some sort of
report
that's not telling me much I'm gonna
drop that back down well well what if
what if we stopped working when we be
able to let's stop working okay all
right good so now it's asking us what
work have you done it's a fair question
hmm let's just that because I have a
suspicion that if I hit back or up or
anything I'd lemongrass a but it's going
to lose the work that I've done so we
should have about six minutes of work
there we hit save we go in task save so
we've got let's have a look on breaks so
indeed both both brakes of minus a
minute I think maybe it can manipulate
time oh they can't possibly mean
negative i think what it's saying is
that so this is essentially like double
accounting so this is minus a minute in
that it's a minute away for a total of a
little slow right so this makes sense
but in the way that is described here
it's kind of backwards so i understand
from your accounting perspective that it
represents a negative number but in
terms of breaks i'm looking at this
going how am i spending minus time on a
morir so you should probably make sure
that everything is in the correct you
know orientation is well wonderful ways
don't say detailing yeah see you're
right that it's it's very similar w
double column accounting but the thing
that makes double count I'll calm
accounting understandable is that there
are in fact your columns yeah that's
kind of the case so you can only really
you know it makes it appropriate if you
have sort of your work time and your
brakes next to each other then it makes
sense if not as in here it kind of
doesn't need no expenses no also details
etc so I think the key piece of
information from what we've looked at
here is really that you want to make it
obvious to the user what their actions
are going to do so in this case even
though we hit cancel and it said that
the action which we had tried to perform
had been cancelled it hadn't been right
it's still here we still have the brake
which is frankly what the user wants and
expects and so we're glad that it does
behaves this way
don't tell me that it's cancelled if
it's not cancelled really all you're
saying here is you didn't put in a
description and frankly the the use case
where you're going to want to go in
there and not n type something and then
not keep whatever you've typed is pretty
much pretty close to zero right yeah
well especially if you have the ability
at it afterwards precise it you can
always change it so it sort of really in
that case it should only be there should
only be one thing you can do there which
is basically edit that break which is
exactly what you're doing so you want to
edit it and then return back to where
you were so you don't need you don't
need to confirm save you don't need to
cancel you don't need to do anything
other than be able to exit back so it
should really just you know everything
should take you back one step and
successfully safe yeah exactly so the
other thing so if we you know I wouldn't
mind also the ability to I mean if I'm
gonna keep track of breaks like that
show and if I actually want to fill in
details which by the way I don't I am so
glad that I don't work on a job that
where that is even remotely necessary
what if I did I wouldn't want to type I
mean what do i do like I went to get
coffee go to the bathroom you know go
smoke um buy drugs any of these things I
like most cigarettes of course or I mean
this is the state of California it's
very true I point is I have a limited
number of thing I would like to have
some defaults absolutely yeah defaults
would be nice it would be good if it
remembers the the sorts of things that
you do in your break or even the work
tasks are you being so ideal strap right
because you know you could just say yeah
you know it at at 9am I always have my
coffee at eleven-thirty I kill someone
at noon I have lunch all these things
can you walk hide the body right yeah
and this is that I mean so obviously
will be nice to just remember an
auto-fill if you want it to be really
really really special you would keep
track of those brake switch to occur at
the same time and say oh in taking a
break at nine it's probably coffee
refill it with coffee and then you can
always change it with most of these
things it's going to be the same
repetitive tasks over and over again
particular
when it comes to brakes and I this is
what I've noticed about all time keeping
tools because I've seen a lot of them
hmm they the simpler they are and the
less interaction they take the better
they work absolutely so for instance one
of the ultimate timekeeping tools that I
suffered for software engineering I just
keeps track of whether you're typing or
not nice very simple it's I built a time
time keeping up myself and it was
exactly the same principle you don't
want to have to do much really the only
thing you want to be a want to have to
do you say I'm switching to another task
and frankly you don't even necessarily
want to say what that task is at the
time you just want to hit one button and
be able to move on with actual work
because every time you're having to fill
in the timesheet you're not working
exactly and sadly very few companies
will let you put timesheet management in
your timesheet as a task no that would
be is unfortunate because I yeah there
was a couple of jobs where I had to fill
out three different time sheets at
half-hour intervals so that was fun I
haven't filled out a timesheet since I
was like 22 that's nice yeah I then
again I never did I never did contract
work yeah you never take control over
the beginning oh yeah in the finance
industry where are they care they care a
lot they do indeed so we're not going to
spend too much time on this one because
we've already i think given most of the
feedback but the key thing i wanted to
point out here is that what do i do if i
want to work on a different project so
you've got the you've got the Friday
games review coming up later today I'm
going to producing that as well how do
we how do we set this up so that we can
now what I'm against a different job
soon it's a product yes so you've
discovered it which is nice now while
we're going through this what I actually
quite like here is that as you're
putting through all of the details you
can actually hit this button and it'll
figure out the office details for you
those just quite nice you know anything
which makes me in 25 Charleston we are
but I'm going to give it that okay what
it might also be even more useful is to
do a geocoding reverse lookup and figure
out what businesses are in the nearby
vicinity let me do not yeah because
really cool chances are i'm more
interested in the company than then i am
in the actual specific location but as I
wanted to highlight this so now see I
guess my problem here is that this this
navigation so we are using this
appropriately for navigation but it's
not immediately obvious that all of
these other things exist in export and
files don't really fit that category
they should kind of probably be in the
overflow menu with something that you
can always get to and so you're really
only looking at timesheets and projects
and so I would client so I'm not
certainly not endorsing Earth's
yeah so and I'm certainly not endorsing
a dashboard pattern but but I think in
this instance where you've got this sort
of amount of space here on your on your
homepage effectively it might be useful
to have a way right here of being able
to initiate but and that's the thing you
can I see ok I've got app clinic um I
drop that down i assume that if i had
more projects i would have more things
miss Ross knows jack the thing is when
i'm looking at this that's a natural
time for me to be thinking oh I need
another ones i wouldn't mind having a
birthday a new project in there yeah so
i think it's it's reasonable to have
this here in the navigation both time
feed some projects but i think what you
want here because this is the screen
what is your name what if i just had the
you know there's a plus but there is a
plus arm it's the wrong post button it
is it's actually the Bayer Aspirin
button it is the mayor has been funny
yeah that's a trademark infringement all
over the place ah so now I have okay add
add task alright i guess i was in the
task view is that so i think the idea
here is that for every project you have
tasks so necessary that you went and
bought donuts for the app clinic and so
you add that task into this project that
there's a task that you consistently
fail out yes it really is now so yeah so
let's just have a quick look you can add
tags what work ever made none I've
failed about location feeling pretty sad
about it not quite sure what the feeling
is for but I kind of like it and there's
no way to just so there's no description
or anything else for the for this task
is just basically the description the
summary where I hit save
so again it's not it's not entirely
clear what that means if we go back here
it seems like I've gone back twice
projects so now the navigation is broken
I'm sort of like wait I didn't navigate
that many parts in and this task that I
just said where does it live what does
it do do I need to have been working in
order to create the task so the the way
that all the things join together how do
projects and tasks and breaks and work
how does that all fit together it should
be obvious I shouldn't have to figure it
out because as he instead I don't want
to have to fill out a timesheet to begin
with I'm only doing this either because
my employer requires it or because I
need to be able to keep track of who the
bill right and the so you want to do as
little thinking as possible when it
comes to to filling in that so you want
to have a really clear flow of
navigation through each of those tasks
and I think you know as a homepage this
is really nice it shows you what you're
working on and sort of one click to
start which is great and so if you can
have ways to to link to new projects and
new tasks as appropriate directly from
that I think you're onto something and
you also i think want to you want to
simplify this navigation so once you get
into the project side it all starts to
get a little complicated with so here's
the task so once again thing could they
could really just turn this into a
winner is integration with something on
in the cloud and even just a simple you
know say App Engine database soon I
where I could you know bring this down
as a spreadsheet edit it in let's say
Google Docs or your your favorite
documentation tool and be able to set
some of this stuff up on the computer
where I've got a full-size keyboard and
I don't mind doing some of this
absolutely so that's you know that's
something which when I was experimenting
with various Google a POS before I
joined Google it did exactly that so
it's a actually saved everything
straight into google calendar so you can
see exactly what task you performed and
then there's a script that ran on a
server which passed the calendar and
created a a google doc spreadsheet which
was the actual time sheet that is really
cool which was tidy and you know i like
that because it meant that I could you
know record the information on my phone
but then when it came to actually saving
it and producing it and printing it out
it was all done you know in the cloud so
nice yeah I've never hooked any
up to my Google Calendar like that
because I think it would it would
demonstrate exactly how much my time is
wasted every single day so yeah it's a
little depressing really you could be
yeah so but anyway it's just these two
or hours a week that I get anything well
at least you get those two hours it's
important so yeah I think that would be
the other piece of functionality devices
definitely could up to the cloud somehow
it doesn't need to be through a Google
specific product but some way to know
that what I've entered in here is going
to be recorded and saved somewhere I
think it's really really vital exactly
so what else we got here do we want to
have a quick look at time sheets on the
on the tablet seizure day if they've
optimized for tablets so they say
they've got a new design ok so this in
this kid well so I haven't set this apps
as it's asking me for a new project
which again will be our mobile
all right and oh I have a save button
here um ok so that's that's actually a
nice Omo again uh can you jiggle the
hdmi cable a little bit oh yeah
beautiful every else all right there you
go so but now I'm missing my I wanted
either mr. go back up well I'm just a
little coffee cup now I do too and
particularly cuz you've got all this
white space no you're not clutter diet
and what I really want is I want a big
red start yeah Oh that'd be great
absolutely and maybe even shaped as
usually I don't suggest going away from
androids darling but an actual like big
button absolutely clinic I would go for
that definite and let's just you know if
you have a look at there's actually a
really good one on istockphoto cost like
seven bucks I think it would be worth it
so you know in fact I think in this in
this particular instance when you're
working on tablet this is your view
right and so I think you almost want to
avoid having that entire you know this
this view is much less valuable you want
to basically start in projects then use
your drop down to be able to navigate
between projects the same with the gmail
lets you choose labels so you're always
looking at this and I would you know
having an extra fragment somewhere in
Ray's own now if i go to tasks here and
one thing that okay so i do have an add
new tasking action just this now this 0
kind of in the middle here is a little
confusing at me particularly I think
because you know we have this this nice
style that we saw earlier of the sort of
cursive Lee written hints think that
would be much nicer here you don't have
any tasks you know click the add tasks
button to to add something I think would
really add
all right go should I think I may be a
little okay you're right I'm you happy
now I'm a bad rep reasonably happy you
know I don't like to get martinis as
much as beer yeah we'll be happy later
than I dude ok so
what did I do ah so now you're viewing
the task and so this is a really
interesting example of why the
navigation doesn't quite work right
because what you really want is to just
have this task view within this fragment
scenario so you basically want to have
this view so you'd basically on a on a
tablet you never want to be getting rid
of this size this side row that should
be your kind of your control pad this is
where you choose your projects it's
where you start working have your breaks
everything lives there and then the
detail all comes in on the right hand
side so I'd say you know it seems like
the tablet layout is relatively new I
would say you're on the right track
definitely keep going along those lines
but try and come up with more ways to be
able to really reduce those that
navigation floor well let me have two
eyes the same mice are absolutely on the
right track of doing everything right
yeah you're not doing anything stupid
there's just a you know a few things you
can probably think through how you could
reduce the amount of complexity in the
app absolutely yeah reduce complexity
reduce the navigation I think if you
stick anyone who's who knows vaguely you
know someone who uses timesheets but has
no idea about your appt set them in
front of it and I just watch them try
and figure out how to do things and
every time they click something and then
go back and click something else trying
to find it in something yeah but you
know for finishing it for adding details
all of these things you know maybe it
really just needs to be a completely
separate flow yeah yeah all right let's
let's move on now while we've still got
a few more minutes and squeeze that
across yes let's have a look at invoice
to go I think okay have a quick look at
that one so we can have to breathe
through the next couple a little more
quickly i think you know i always
happens oh it always does i'm going to
zoom in on the phone camera I can see it
happening just as exciting yes it's
going to happen any minute now blue
there yes look at that oh nice so this
this is a invoice to go
what I think is interesting is that the
invoice to go action barb bomb well this
is really really weird because you'd
think that if the title in the action
bar is radioactive yak hmm and there is
a way to add multiple companies which
where you might be switching between
companies it seems like radioactive yaks
should be a drop-down tool on the left
hand side which is of course see ya
Saudi so what happens if you add another
company let's have a look start a new
company and you company so this is the
the workflow when you begin so this is
how you basically go through and decide
what the invoice is going to look like
for your company really are quite a
quite a few nice I don't us yeah quite a
lot of nice ones let's go with let's go
with fresh so we can choose all that
different fields I'm not going to go
through all these in detail company name
see
so if the the app clinic we need to give
an address so again this would be a nice
opportunity to maybe figure that I'm
putting in the details where I currently
am that's how ya do I need all of them
yes I do owe you but you need to address
line to address on Tish is your sting
the truth is that data validation when
you're enforcing business rules is
important but I think people take it too
far I think that when when you're
writing something that's you know going
to be handed off to a data entry clerk
it's nice to have some validation when
you're doing the setup however um maybe
not something that's my company I get to
decide exactly how it should appear on a
dress form so yeah if exactly so let me
skip all of these as well minor point
you don't need the EEG to preset to
prepend each of these you just have the
other sample stuff and in fact even the
phone cell facts etc isn't kind of a
standard where that you do here in text
you want to know yeah you just want to
show what they should be putting in
there and let them put them in there
themselves so here you just have a phone
instead of eg phone yeah oh you would
just have the phone number you just have
five five five dash 55 55 well as an
example okay that's certainly what you
would do for email no sorts of things
are good suck now this is interesting in
that we're not doing any validation on
the cell phone numbers chances are
you're only going to use numbers and
maybe dashes so you want to set the
keyboard type appropriately
except that tax rate sure and then we're
done so now we're back in mash and again
so now we want to choose a different
company then we go through this so that
seems a little unfortunate that's
something is the action bar navigation
pattern is pretty solid absolutely
people are going to expect that I think
in this instance it makes it obvious
sense you know if you have the company
name here you're going to expect that
that drop-down is going to let you
choose exactly particularly as you you
know you go into this action bar style
very quickly I'll switch companies
otherwise this is kind of a dashboard
pattern which I guess kind of makes
sense in this instance in that you're
just trying to do these particular
things it doesn't really make sense to
drop you into any one of them
independently but i wonder how does this
look on the on the tablet but i think i
actually have a pretty nice tablet
layout on its its unconventional no it's
actually quite different from the air
from the phone yeah it really is um so
the there's a couple things that I want
to point it out you know first the
action bar of course is just as useful
as a woman is to say no particular well
not as much and then they have this this
area over here on the left now that's
really interesting to me um it's it's
unconventional I don't dislike it I find
it to be useful but there is actually a
pattern which we just added which is
called they help me out here the drawer
the drawer absolutely yeah if you look
for the drawer pattern I you've seen
variations on this in several apps of
facebook app edit the Google+ app the
YouTube app so a lot of requests for it
to be added to the design pattern so the
design team sat down looked at all of
the variations on this and sort of try
to figure out which ones were most
effective and most like other Android
patterns yeah so what we settled on is
something where you can slide this in
and out usually you don't just see icons
usually is a sizable impact yeah it
should always be under the action bar
never over the top it never pushes the
action bar over that's right action bar
is a first class citizen it's always
there today's at the top of your app
writing system lies in in point of fact
I think it was YouTube was actually
implementing all of our suggest that's
right and I think all of the examples on
the design sought use YouTube so if you
wander a couch it at work how's it look
in practice definitely check out the
latest YouTube app indeed I so this is
very very close to the drawer pattern
the injury pattern is basically saying I
have a fairly complicated bit of
navigation more than is really sensible
for the drop-down area yeah and so and I
don't want it to always necessarily be
visible yeah I I think I would switch to
that now over here in the main area
we've got the original sort of dashboard
idea and then some extra stuff um I
don't eat it but I I can't rationally
defend it it does look like what can we
put here to fill up some space right
yeah i'm not sure what the right
solution is oh I wonder if their
children if we go to an invoice right I
right now I'm kind of bugged by this
because now it's using the entire screen
and I kind of would like to still have
some yeah yeah yeah exactly um you know
maybe even just you know and this is all
create right yeah you know maybe what I
would like is to see oh so that's my
products for you I guess this okay now
this is what I want hmm ok I've got
invoices and add invoice yeah
and to me I a I don't want to go to this
screen I i want the ad in voice activity
to be a fragment inside here I think
that makes a ton more sense yeah I I
would like the invoices to be listed
over on the left whereas right now I
think this is more you know most likely
it's going to be all the vices yeah and
I think that that's really what we've
been getting at is in general this is
you know I would call this like the the
windows explorer or finder type of view
on something where you've got this sort
of folder idea over on the left and then
a list view on the right and that that
almost never feels right to me no it's
not it's not quite right not oh no not
on a mobile device on a phone or a
tablet where you don't want to have to
navigate you don't want to have to think
about things being sort of in this
hierarchical folder structure there's
really no reason why you can't sort of
have everything kind of on the left
mm-hmm exactly especially since they've
already gone hierarchical with this so
it wouldn't be that hard to just say
okay I'm going to open up my invoices
and see them listed underneath invoices
and then I could see the invoice details
get over on the right have a big plus
icon next to each of the category so you
can add any way an invoice new estimate
purchase order etc yeah I think I would
probably prefer that yeah so again it's
basically the same sort of story that
we've been saying all the time which is
to simplify your navigation as much as
possible you don't want to have every
time you change the entire screen you're
changing the context in which you're
working which means you need to take a
few seconds to figure out what just
happened where am I what do I have to do
the less you can is actually something
that you know they've done cognitive
studies where when you change context I
it's the habit of your brain to actually
forget what you were doing hmm it's why
and they've shown this like every time
you go through
or yes I've seen this so this is why you
you go into another room and then ask
yourself why am I here now I do that
because I'm old but other people do that
because of these talking evening so yeah
so yeah everything every time you switch
something completely and I think that's
really what i'm getting rain is it's not
that I don't like the layout here it's
not that I strongly object is just the
fact that to get anything done to see
anything useful I have to pick something
that is going to take me to a completely
new area right some of these are worse
than others you know it's so to view an
invoice you know it sort of took me over
to the right we're now I've got this
list view here so I don't hate that as
much but to add an invoice just
completely on you see ya yeah completely
new stream and definitely not sort of
tablet-optimized either you know for
something like this so that is confusing
and invoice so something like this way
you've got a huge amount of white space
now obviously once you've got the items
that may change but it may not even be a
bad thing here to actually have the
white space around the borders rather
than in the middle of your screen
because this this part here in the
middle this is where you actually are
going to be paying attention that's
where the user is going to be looking
but all the important stuff is on the
edges so I think if I had to choose the
the most Android way to do this it would
probably be to have this left-hand
navigation area be expressed as either
action bar navigation or as a view pager
hmmm uh yeah if you paid you actually
would be cologne Ross I think here so
click between them if you don't actually
need to see them next week we never even
see this instead we always see this view
hmm so we have the view of the you know
the master view here we have a detailed
view here that's actually a detailed
view instead of another master view yeah
and then I could you know page through
either by dropping down or doing some
paging here or using the drawer I mean
there's any number of ways that I could
do that and be quiet I wouldn't waste
this kind of space on what's essentially
a navigation yeah because keep in mind
as well that these things don't actually
have anything in common the
commonalities that they're all pieces of
paper that you have to generate for your
business to either charge someone pay
someone be paid but having them listed
here sort of implies a hierarchy that
doesn't really exist not so much so just
having them separated by navigation or I
quite like the idea of having the the
viewpager so you scroll between your
invoices and your estimates it's not a
huge number so it doesn't become
unwieldy your hard to find sir but yet I
mean that's your call something to
experiment with perhaps about to rock
casa de great so I think we've we've
offered a lot of constructive feedback
on apps that we thought were really
quite good there were a few apps that
said that we don't have time to look at
in exhaustive detail um quite honestly I
didn't think that they were quite as
good mmm is a finance East oh well I
struggled with this one so I opened this
up and pretty quickly turned it back off
because I really didn't understand what
I was yeah I'm not sure now maybe if I
was considerably more wealthy because I
did notice that I have the ability to do
all sorts of things in this application
in any currency I want nice something
like 200 built-in currencies and
including special drawing rights which
who has those right uh yeah um
and I can also use my own made-up
currency well that's so so with my own
symbol and everything so I made up
Twitter bucks with of course the at sign
as a symbol nice as you know I'm Victini
Lewis bucks but well now I didn't make
nearly as much since uh so well in that
of course is what I'm paying my minions
excellent that's interesting but this
this kind of surprised me too is like I
could see that I could add budget items
but as far as I can tell each budget is
partly red and partly green for no
apparent reason really really not
understanding it seems like it's just
that I haven't paid it because I don't
have a transaction maybe I mean in other
words there's this is one of those
things where there's obviously a lot of
power yeah absolutely but it makes no
sense yeah it so it fails the i've just
installed this app how do i get started
test I can't see when I start this up I
don't see what is what is the value what
can I do what is this giving me that
some other app hasn't and so I've just
downloaded a bunch of budgeting apps
then I'm kind of stuck here because I
load it up and if we we switch to the
phone of you I haven't put anything into
this one yet so we should be able to
fire it up and
and this is kind of what you're
presented with at startup and it's it's
kind of it's the old school model so
it's a gingerbread type tabs and buttons
and everything else which is already a
bit off-putting there's no title bar or
action bar so again there's no context
hint as to what am i doing how am I
supposed to do things and it just says
you should get started by creating
account by hitting the plus and then
title which doesn't quite make sense
because my accounts have titles I I
guess it which feels like it should be
name or description or something well
that's a that's a minor it is another
thing but it just it goes to the whole
flow of being like I'm not quite sure
what they want or what this is for how
this is going to help me and if you
compare that to the other apps we've
looked at it became pretty obvious
straight away like oh okay so this is
for creating invoices first thing I do
is choose what the universe looks like
then you understand right off the bat
that ok so this is probably going to
create invoices for me of course my
major objection to this is just it with
with the state of things now I am much
more likely to use something that can
hook into my actual bank account because
all of my things are done electronically
and I think that's why I gravitate
towards something like mint com yeah all
right we're just about out of time the
one app that we didn't really look at
was I owe you the truth is I owe you is
up you know that I'm gonna be honest oh
I was never a huge fan of hollow I ok
from from the beginning I said to myself
it's interesting that we want to be all
like holographic and tron style I don't
personally like it so with that in mind
now what I'm about to say may be
complete you know just a completely a
personal problem but i find this black
screen to be off-putting well i think
you know i would be helpful if we had
Roman here to confirm but I think
general we found that for most sort of
data entry things anything other than
media the holo light theme is sort of
more visually pleasing over the white
backgrounds
light action bar rather than dark dark
works well for things like youtube or
for video playing there you go anything
whether sort of the content is front and
center and what you're looking at is
really important so you want everything
else to sort of fade into the back well
I think we can just say there's a rule
of thumb here is if you're going to be
using this app while wearing your little
black dress and it should be Jolla dark
and if you're going to be wearing it
wearing your white shirt and tie then it
should be whole light yeah I think
that's something which I brought a fun
very useful little boy especially those
who wear both are certain a little in
Bible breath dress maybe this we weren't
going to talk about this on it really
yeah anything on really unique so I we
we don't have time to discuss it more it
does actually seem like it's got some
nice functionality we might want to
cover it more what am I having to look
it generally speaking it keeps things
simple it's obvious what is for not
overly complicated navigation so they've
been do a few things right yeah you know
as nice as you can so it would be nice
if that was a new pager so you can say
it's nice that you can select between
them I'm yeah right now I'm wondering
why can't I swipe between them yeah
alright so in that falls into the bucket
that we talked about earlier which is if
you make something that looks like a
standard app Android UI element I you
know if you have to implement your own
if you want to implement your own Bravo
to you you're completely wasting your
time but if you do make sure that it
operates in exactly the same way because
otherwise people will just be frustrated
yeah i mean honestly it's like getting
into a car and finding out that the
brakes on the right and the gas is on
the left that's not going to end well i
had a problem i can go to the US but in
the car and found the entire steering
assembly was on the wrong side of the
car yeah well it's a you know it when
you come to a different operating system
let's say it you off you need to attend
but i think you have probably will have
noticed that every car in the United
States drives that way and so even
though it may appear completely wrong
consistency is a virtue absolutely as
they say adapt or die in some cases a
little more literally than others indeed
all right that's all we have time for
today folks so well thank you very much
for joining us I let us know on our
Google+ page what you think in today's
show if you like us to I don't know
bring back the hangouts or switch
microphones again or anything else let
us know what you think and until next
week I am yin dee luis i'm a writer mine
and we'll see you guys later I Wilson
fact we'll see you next week for music
players I think I believe it yeah music
players that should be a really
interesting show and yeah see you next
week